وافقت الحكومه الاسرائيليه على اختصار
اجراءات التصديق على البناء الاستيطاني
ومنحت وزير الماليه رئيس حزب الصهيونيه
الدينيه المتطرف صلاحيه التصديق على بناء
المستوطنات بالتزامل مع استعداد تل ابيب
لبحث بناء 4000
وحده استيطانيه بالضفه وقد دانت السلطه
الفلسطينيه القرار ووصفته بانه تصعيد خطير
يمهد الاستكمال ضم الضفه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما مغزى تصديق الحكومه
الاسرائيليه على قرار اختصار اجراءات
البناء الاستيطاني وما دلالات تفويض وزير
يمينيه متطرف سلطه البتي في بناء مسوطنات
جديده بالضفار وعلى اي نحو سينعكس تسارع
وتيره الاستيطان على مستقبل الضفه وما
امكانيه ان تشكل هذه الخطوه مقدمه لتصعيد
اسرائيلي اكبر ينتهي باستكمال ضم الضفاد
وما خيارات السلطه الفلسطينيه للتصدي لهذا
المشروع وما الموقف الامريكي منه
ومنعكاساته المحتمله على التفاهمات
السابقه مع الاسرائيليين بشان وقف
الاستيطان
[موسيقى]
بالتزامن مع استعداد ما يعرف بالمجلس
الاعلى للتخطيط والبناء في اسرائيل لبحث
مخططات بناء اربعه الاف وستمائه وخمسين
وحده استيطانيه جديده بالضفه الغربيه منحت
الحكومه الاسرائيليه وزير الماليه
رئيس حزب الصهيونيه الدينيه المتطرف
صلاحيه التصديق على قرارات البناء
الاستيطاني في الضفه الغربيه من دون
الحاجه لموافقه وزير الدفاع قرار ترافق مع
قرار اخر باختصار مراحل اجراءات البناء
الاستيطاني التي كانت تقضي بتمرير اي
مشروع من هذا النوع على لجان تدرسه عبر
اربع مراحل قبل اقراره من وزير الدفاع
الخارجيه الفلسطينيه دانت قرار الحكومه
الاسرائيليه بشان تيسير اجراءات البناء
الاستيطاني في الضفه الغربيه وقالت ان
تفويض وزير الماليه الاسرائيليه تصديق على
الاستيطان تصعيد خطير لاستكمال ضم الضفار
وكانت الخارجيه الفلسطينيه طلبت باجبار
الحكومه الاسرائيليه على وقف اجراءاتها
احاديه الجانب وغير القانونيه وقالت انها
تقوض فرصه تطبيق مبدا حل الدولتين وقرارات
الشرعيه الدوليه والاتفاقات الموقعه اما
حركه حماس فقد دانت مسمته تهويد الارض
الفلسطينيه وقالت ان مثل هذه القرارات لن
تمنح الاحتلال شرعيه على الارض الفلسطينيه
وان الشعب الفلسطيني سيقاومها بكل الوسائل
المتاحه
[موسيقى]
مناقشه هذا الموضوع معنى من الناصره
الدكتور سليم بريك المحاضر في العلوم
السياسيه بالجامعه المفتوحه والخبير في
الشؤون الاسرائيليه ومن واشنطن جيم موران
عضو مجلس النواب الامريكي السابق عن الحزب
الديمقراطي مرحبا بكما سيد مراد معك
الحكومه الامريكيه اذا هي في الاساس يعني
لديها تحفظات على وزراء اليمين المتطرف
ووضعت الان الحكومه الاسرائيليه في يده
مساله البت بعمليه التوسع الاستيطاني وهو
نهجه الذي اعلنه بكل صراحه كيف ينظر لمثل
هذا الموقف من الحكومه الاسرائيليه
بالنسبه
لما ترغبه واشنطن
اعتقد ان واشنطن سوف ترد بالكلمات فقط
وبالكلمات التي لا تعني اي شيء على
الاطلاق اداره بايدن قالت
عندما تقول انها
تاسفوا بشده
لاي اجراء هذا لا يعني شيئا لان حكومه
نتنياهو تعرف ذلك تعرف انها ممكن ان تتصرف
بمنعه عن اي ردود فعل او عقوبات وواشنط لا
تستخدم ابدا ما لديها من وسائل الضغط ضد
هذه الحكومه الفاشيه
الناس يقولون انه المتحده ترحل عن الشرق
الاوسط المتحده لا ترحل عن الشرق الاوسط
ما زال لدينا ثلاثين الف عسكري ونبيع وما
قيمتهم مليارات الدولارات من السلاح
للسعوديه لاسرائيل لكننا نرحل عن الشرق
الاوسط بطريقه واحده وهي التخلي عن واجبنا
الاخلاقي وطالما اننا
نغمض عيوننا عن هذا العمل الاخلاقي اعتقد
ان المساله مخيبه للغايه هم لا يقلون
سوءا عن اداره ترامب فيما يتعلق بقضيه
اسرائيل نحن نعرف ما يعنيه ذلك الامر لا
يتعلق بما هو صح او خطا صواب او لا بل
تبعات السياسه الداخليه
لافهم اكثر الموقف الامريكي هل هي غير
راغبه بممارسه الضغوط او يعني تفعيل
الوسائل وسائل الضغط على الحكومه
الاسرائيليه انها غير مهتمه بما يجري في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه وغير مهتمه بالعمليه
التي طالما دعت اليها وهي عمليه السلام
القائمه على اساس حل الدولتين والاتفاقيات
الموقعه سيد مراد
القضيه انها لا تعنينهم لا يعبئون لكنهم
لا يمتلكون الشجاعه الاخلاقيه لتطبيق
قيامهم يعرفون ما هو خطا وما هو الصواب
يعرفون انما تقوم به الحكومه الاسرائيليه
هو لا اخلاقي
ويتنافى مع القيم ولا قانوني وهذا امر لا
يمكن ان يستمر الحكومه الامريكيه
لا ترقى الى مستوى الدفاع عن مبادئها
والواقع السياسي الامريكي مخيب انا
توقعت منهم اكثر لان الاداره الامريكيه
التي تتصدى
اللوبي الاسرائيلي هي لا تتصدى لنتنياهو
هي تتصدى اللوبيا الاسرائيلي واللوبي
الاسرائيلي يدرك جيدا انه يمكن ان يتلاعب
به كلا الحزبين لي عليهما ما يشاء مؤخرا
قالوا ان اي اي اداره او اي حزب يفعل ما
لا يشاؤون سينفقون من المال ما سيؤدي الى
هزيمتهم اللعبه الاسرائيلي يعرف انهم
يسيطرون على الاداره ويصطرون على الكونغرس
وعلى كلا الحزبين
لو ان بعض السياسيين وقف شامخا مدافعا عن
قيمه فان قضيه الشرق الاوسط
ستتغير لكن طالما ذلك بقي مجرد كلامه وحتى
بدون كلام بدون افعال ولا نقوم هو صواب
ولا نستخدمه ما لدينا من قدره على الضغط
سيبقى واقع الحال مخيبا لكل من يؤمن
بالولايات المتحده ويؤمن
بالقيمه الاساس من ورائي ان اسرائيل
كابلاد ديمقراطيه ليبراليه صغيره تحترم
حقوق الانسان وتحترمه استقبال حكم القانون
وهي ديمقراطيه لكنها الان تتحكم بها حكومه
نتنياهو بشكل نجعلها مختلفه تماما اما
كانت تصور من وراء انشائها
وتعامل الشعب الفلسطيني بهذه الطريقه
المهينه هذا امر فظيع مريع لكنه حقيقي
لاننا لا نفعل شيء كحكومه تجاهه سيد سليم
نتنياهو اذا هو يعني اطلق هذه الوعود
والان يفي بتعهداته لهذه الحكومه اليمنيه
الاشد التطرفا التي جاءت باجنده واضحه
ومعلنه احدها الاستيطان الكبير في الضفه
الغربيه
بغض النظر طبعا عن كل السياقات الداخليه
ان كان داخليه الاسرائيليه او الاقليميه
او الدوليه ما مغزى اتخاذ نتنياهو القرار
الان بهذه الصوره
اتخاذ القرار بهذه الصوره هو عمليا تطبيق
للاتفاق الائتلافيه الذي ابرم بين اللكود
بقياده نتنياهو بين صهيونيه الدينيه
بقياده سمتريج يعني هذه الحكومه منذ
قيامها هي حكومه استيطان نتنياهو طبعا لم
يخفي في الماضي استيائه من اتفاقيات اوسلو
ولم يخفي في الماضي انه معني بالسيطره على
كل الضفه الغربيه وانه لا مكان لدوله اخرى
غرب نهر الاردن وهذا موجود في كتابات
نتنياهو المتعدده الان نحن نرى مثلا في
الاتفاق الائتلاف الذي ابرم مع الصهيونيه
الدينيه انه يجب ان
عمليا ان تضم الضفه الغربيه وان يكون
القانون الاسرائيلي هو الساري في الضفه
الغربيه هناك ايضا بند 120 في الاتفاق
الائتلافي ومفصل جدا مثلا والعوده الى
القرار 106 من سنه 1981
حكومه مناح التي تقول بان الاستيطان
اليهودي هو
مشروع في كل اماكن الضفه الغربيه على
الاطلاق
فاذا نتنياهو ينفذ اولا ايديولوجيه
نتنياهو
اليمين الريبزيونيستي او يمين الاصلاحي ما
يسمى من ناحيه ومن ناحيه اخرى هو يتفق في
هذا الموضوع مع الصهيونيه الدينيه الان
التنفيذ هذا الاتفاق ايضا له اتبعات
اقتصاديه يقوم بتنفيذها وزير الماليه ومن
هو وزير الماليه هو اسمه الان
ماذا تستطيع سلطه الفلسطينيه فعله انا لا
ادري ولكن الولايات المتحده التي طالما
دعت بانها وسيط هي عمليا تدعم هذا
الاستيطان يعني وزير الدفاع جالنت التقى
مع الوزير اوستن قبل عده ايام وعلى ما
يبدو بان جلنت فهم من هذا اللقاء ان هناك
ضوء اخضر للاستمرار في هذا الاستيطان وعلى
الاقل في ابتلاع المنطقه سي بالمناسبه
يعني
نتنياهو يرى وحكومه ليس من الان ان
المنطقه سي ستكون الحل لارتفاع اسعار
البيوت والبناء في دوله اسرائيل باعتبار
ان هذه الاراضي هي اراضي
بالمجان وبهذه الطريقه يستطيعون عمليا زرع
المستوطنات هو شرعت المستوطنات والبؤر
الاستيطانيه التي لم تكن شرعيه حتى الان
ونحن نرى مثلا في اتفاق الائتلاف تحويل
هذه المناطق لمناطق تماس امنيه اي انه من
الناحيه الاقتصاديه هناك
عطاءات
من الضرائب لصالح من يذهب ليسكن هناك وهذا
ينفذ سياسه التي تحدث عنها في الماضي وهي
مليون مستوطن في الضفه الغربيه خلال
السنوات القادمه سيد مراد طبعا بطبيعه
الحال السلطه الفلسطينيه تحدثت بان مثل
هذا
القرار الصادر اليوم مع كل هذه العطاءات
بالنسبه لعمليه البناء في الضفه الغربيه
المعلن عنها كان في شهر فبراير ش
عشره الاف وحده سكنيه الان يجري الذهاب
الى 4,650 وحده استيطانيه جديده هذا يصب
حسب وجهه نظر السلطه في مشروع الضم الذي
تخطط له ضم الضفه
لاسرائيل والذي تخطط له الحكومه
الاسرائيليه لاي درجه واشنطن هي واعيه
وتتشاطر مع السلطه الفلسطينيه مثل هذا هذه
الرؤيه وهذا الكلام عن الضم
هناك الكثير من التغافل
والجهل المتعمد لان هناك من لا يريد
الاقرار بالواقع لانها غير مريحه كما كان
اوباما يسويها الوقائع غير المريحه او
الحقائق غير المريحه طبعا هي الاداره تفقد
مصداقيتها لا ادري ماذا سيفعلون الامر
يذكرنا بزعماء الهنود الحمر عندما بدا
المستوطنون البيض جاءوا واستوروا على
الاراضي وقتلوا القبائل افراد القبائل
الهنديه الزعماء اراد ان يفعل شيئا لكنهم
لم يكونوا قادرين على ذلك اعتقد ان هذا
الحكومه الاسرائيليه
ستفلت من العقوبه بما تفعله ربما حتى ما
يسمى ضد الشعب الفلسطيني
لانهم لا يهتمون لا بحقوق الشعب الفلسطيني
ولا
بمقتضيات
العداله كل ما يريدونه وتوسيع اسرائيل
الكبرى بكل صراحه اقول الامر متروك الان
للمليون مستوطن ان يفعلوا ما شاؤون على
الارض الفلسطينيه
وربما اربعين اربع ملايين
فلسطيني ماذا سيفعلون لان المليون مستوطن
اسرائيلي سيحصلون على مصادر المياه
وسيطرون على نهر الاردن وعلى مصادر المياه
الاخرى وهم سوف
يكرهون الفلسطينيين على الرحيل او على
التخلي عن الزراعه واشنطن تعرفوا كل هذا
لكنها لا تمتلك الشجاعه ولا الايمان
بالحقيقه مبادئها على اي شيء عذر عن
الكلمات الجوفاء دكتور بريك
السلطه الفلسطينيه تحدثت ايضا بان يعني
بالاضافه
لموضوع الضم تحدثت بان هذا ما يجري على
الارض في الضفه الغربيه يلغي حل الدولتين
حديث مثل هذا من هذا النوع يعني عن حل
الدولتين الى اي درجه ممكن ان يكون هو
حديث واقعي في ظل ما شهدته الضفه وما هو
مخطط لها
اولا حل الدولتين انتهى يعني حتى الولايات
المتحده التي تتحدث عن حل الدولتين هي
تتحدث يعني فقط
للضريبه الكلاميه وليس اكثر الحكومه
الاسرائيليه لا تؤمن بحل الدولتين نتنياهو
صرح بهذا الموضوع منذ سنوات اوسلو من
سنوات التسعين يعني لا يوجد شيء جديد في
هذا الموضوع السلطه الفلسطينيه
مغلوب على امره حاليا وباعتقاده انها فشلت
فشل ذريع حتى في الساحه الدبلوماسيه
والولايات المتحده هي ليست وسيط هي لا
يمكن ان تكون وسيط لانها احاديه الجانب
وتدعم عمليا الجانب الاسرائيلي وليس فقط
الولايات المتحده حتى بريطانيا نحن سمعنا
بريطانيا الان وزير الداخليه البريطاني
يمرر قانون يمنع السلطات المحليه والمجتمع
المدني في بريطانيا من
محاربه السلع التي تصدر من المستوطنات اي
انا بريطانيا تدعم الاستيطان فاذا كل
الغرب عمليا لا يكترث بابتلاع الضفه
الغربيه من قبل اسرائيل الان يجب ان ننظر
ايضا هي ليست القضيه ليست فقط بناء وحدات
استيطانيه كثيره في الضفه الغربيه فورا
وانما ايضا هناك نقطتين مهمتين النقطه
الاولى اسمه مستوطن هو سيباشر الان بهدم
بيوت فلسطينيه من غير من غير ترخيص كما
يدعون القضيه الثانيه هي موجوده طبعا في
الاتفاق الائتلافي هي شوارع تمتد في خدمه
المستوطنين
وتسمى هناك شوارع امنيه والى اخره هذه
الشوارع ستكون على حساب الاراضي
الفلسطينيه القضيه الاضافيه انه حتى الان
المحكمه العليا في اسرائيل على الاقل
حاولت منع استيطان على اراضي فلسطينيه
خاصه
وسمحت فقط بالاستيطان على اراضي الدوله
وما يسمى الاراضي الدوله اي انها ليست في
ملكيه فلسطينيه خاصه الان حكومه نتنياهو
بقياده ستشرع ايضا بناء مستوطنات وبيوت
على اراضي فلسطينيه خاصه وهذا طبعا تغيير
جذري للواقع في الضفه الغربيه سيد موران
يعني طبعا بطبيعه الحال كل ذلك سيؤدي الى
رده فعل في ظل انحصار خيارات او محدوديه
خيارات السلطه الفلسطينيه سوى التنديد
والمناشده برايك ما طبيعه الرد الذي سيكون
على الارض الواقع من قبل الفلسطيني والذي
سيكون مثلا مقبولا لدى الجانب
الامريكي في واشنطن
رده الفعل الفلسطينيه الوحيده المقبوله
لامريكا واشنطن هو ما توافق عليه ويوافق
عليه اللوبي الاسرائيلي وهو عمل لا شيء هم
ليس لديهم ايه بدائل لا يوجد حل دولتين
حقيقي كل ما تفعله الولايات المتحده هي
تتحدث
نفاقا بكلمات جوفاء لكنها لا تفعل عن اي
شيء هو ليس حلا ولم يعد حلا الحكومه
الاسرائيليه تشعر بانها بحاجه
لاكراه السكان الفلسطينيين ليتخلوا عن
ارضهم لان استمرار عيشهم في ارض ما تزال
تسمى فلسطين في النهايه عددهم سيفوق عدد
الاسرائيليين اذا
ودفع الفلسطينيين واخراجهم من اراضيهم
القانونيه
والحل الوحيد هو طردهم وليس حلا
للازمه للاسف لانهم ليسوا فقط الامريكيين
السعوديون تخلوا عن فلسطينيين والقوا بهم
الى التهلكه الاماراتيون القى
بالفلسطينيين الى التهلكه ولم يعد من يدعم
القضيه الفلسطينيه لان الولايات المتحده
قطعا لا تفعل ذلك
وقد تقوم الصين او روسيا بذلك لكن ايضا
موقفهم لن يكون ذا فاعليه حقيقه الامر
ليضعه الى الخزن خيبه ان يكون الموقف
الروسي مصداقيه واخلاق ارضيه اخلاقيه اكثر
من راتب المتحده للاسف امريكا تسمح بحدوث
ذلك لكن لا ارى اي شيء اخر على ارض الواقع
الدكتور بريك يعني هذا القرار جاء بعد
تفاهمات المعروفه باسم تفاهمات العقبه
وشرم الشيخ الامنيه التي تلزم اسرائيل
بوقف
الاستيطان وخفض التصعيد في الضفه الغربيه
ما مصير مثل هذه التفاهمات التي حضرت فيها
السلطه الفلسطينيه ودول عده بالاضافه
الاسرائيلي والامريكي
[موسيقى]
في المناطق الفلسطينيه تعود طبعا الى
اتفاقات ابرهام الى الدول العربيه التي
طبعت مع اسرائيل ولم تهتم نهائيا في
الموضوع الفلسطيني وكما قد تحدث المتحدث
السابق طبعا السعوديه والامارات والمغرب
وهذه الدول جميعها عمليا لا تهتم في
الموضوع الفلسطيني انظري مثلا الى حتى الى
تمويل اون مثلا على سبيل المثال الدول
العربيه الان تقريبا بغالبيتها لا تساعد
شعب الفلسطيني لا بالاموال ولا بالمواقف
لا في الامم المتحده ولا امام الولايات
المتحده حينما لا يكون ضغط على اسرائيل
تستطيع ان تفعل ما تشاء شكرا لك من
الناصره الدكتور سليم بريك المحاضر في
العلوم السياسيه بالجامعه المفتوحه
والخبير في الشؤون الاسرائيليه واشكر ايضا
ضيفي من واشنطن جيم موران عضو مجلس النواب
الامريكي السابق عن الحزب الديمقراطي شكرا
جزيلا لكما
الى هنا تنتهي هذه الحلقات من برنامج ما
وراء الخبر الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]